But alias and all others
who have asked me how they can apply.
I think I mentioned it already
in a couple of the videos,
but this is how you do it.
If I'm saying that the first thing you want to do
is to enroll in a German course.
If you really are interested in wanting to do this,
you would have to enroll in a German course
first of all.
Secondly,
decide if you want to go through this yourself
or you want to use an agency.
But as I initially stated,
it's a straightforward process
that you wouldn't need to use an agency.
But if you are someone that don't know what.
That doesn't want so much stress
or do things on their own
because you have so much on your plate, then. One.
Look for an agency that recruits nurses to Germany.
I'm giving you two.
I have a video of that already on my page.
But I'm going to write a name again in the caption.
So one is medicrutor. d E.
Medicrutor. d E. Or madness
medness. d e. They recruit nurses from Africa to Germany.
So you need to contact them
and then you take it from there.
They will give you what they require from you.
They would help you
and roll you in an online German course.
And they will guide you through all the process.
And to the best of my knowledge,
you're not supposed to pay anything
unless things Have changed.
Secondly, if you're going to do this yourself,
first go to indeedjobs.com or to telljobs.com.
Or you go to make it in Germany dot d e.
I'm going to write all the names in the captions.
Search for nursing jobs in Germany.
You gonna search a job as a nurse.
And then during the interview,
tell them you wanna come in as a nursing care assistant.
They know how the procedure works.
And then they will take it from there with you.
So start by looking for a job.
Write emails and contact all those individuals
whilst you search for a German cause to enrolling.
I hope this answers your question.
Otherwise you can let me know
and then I'll respond when I'm able to.